le débat sur la fin de vie en France est
ouvert depuis de nombreuses années
notamment via des faits divers qui ont
eu un incroyable retentissement comme
l'affaire Vincent Lambert l'affaire
Chantal Sebire
[Musique]
le suicide assisté et l'euthanasie sont
deux choses différentes car dans
l'euthanasie il y a l'aide d'un tiers
pour provoquer la mort ce n'est pas le
cas dans le suicide assisté ou la
personne en plus fournir un produit
létal mais c'est elle-même qui se
l'administre
[Musique]
la loi sur la fin de vie en France
s'appelle la loi Leonetti classe elle
date de 2016 elle permet d'arrêter les
traitements et si à ce moment-là la
personne souffre elle peut avoir une
sédation profonde et continue jusqu'au
décès c'est à dire
Jean Leonetti son co-auteur l'avait
résumé ainsi c'est dormir avant de
mourir pour ne pas souffrir mais ce
n'est pas un acte létal en soi alors il
y a plusieurs pays en Europe et dans le
monde qui ont légalisé l'euthanasie le
premier d'entre eux les Pays-Bas en 2001
aujourd'hui il y en a 6 en tout la
Belgique
l'Espagne récemment ou encore le
Luxembourg et d'autres pays ont plutôt
opté pour le suicide assisté via une loi
ou sans loi simplement
des pénalisant comme la Suisse ou plus
récemment l'Italie
en France le débat sur l'évolution de la
loi sur la fin de vie est un débat au
long cours qui est récurrent depuis des
dizaines d'années
récemment il y a quand même eu à la
rentrée 2022 un avis du comité national
consultatif d'éthique qui pour la
première fois à ouvrir la porte à une
possibilité de de légaliser l'aide
active à mourir donc après ce feu vert
Emmanuel Macron a annoncé le lancement
d'une convention citoyenne sur la fin de
vie qui travaille actuellement sur sur
la loi sur l'évolution possible de la
loi on sait déjà que une majorité des
citoyens par un système de vote
intermédiaire c'est prononcé en faveur
d'une évolution de la loi on attend
quand même leur travaux définitifs début
avril et à ce moment là
les politiques se saisiront du sujet on
peut s'attendre à une évolution
suicide assister euthanasie les deux on
ne sait pas encore vers où les
politiques vont choisir d'aller